ted there's only one week until some
lower elementary clark county school
district students returned to campus the
start of the transition began today
with a number of educators going back
for the first time since march of last
year
a news now reporter kristen drummond
visited a northwest valley school
to take a look at the transition there's
a bustle of activity here at gerheim
elementary school as staff and teachers
return to campus
and make their final preparations for
students to come back next monday
it feels like the first day of school
all over again i have to go to my
meeting
some anxiety and excitement for
pre-kindergarten to third grade
educators at gerheim
most reporting back to get ready for
hybrid learning
that's a mix of in-person and online
classes during the week
teachers are setting up their classrooms
to keep desks spaced out
the librarian also unpacking cameras
tripods and headphones
to help teachers live stream so students
at home can follow the lessons
most teachers here are assigned a cohort
as well as students in full-time
distance education
that choice was made to keep students
and teachers together
my staff was very responsive of trying
to keep their kids maintain their kids
and was willing to at least come for an
in-person session to serve those kids
that wanted to be in person
but then maintaining the rest of their
class that wanted to be distance
learning
teachers continue adjusting to the
situation and the task of bringing most
children in buildings for the first time
since march
i think it's going to take us a couple
days to figure out what's going to be
the best groove that the kids work well
with ccsd has a website with information
dedicated for only hybrid learning
for a link visit our website
eightnewsnow.com
reporting from the northwest valley
kristin drummond 8 news now
kristen thank you and to help you with
the transition of hybrid learning ccsd
has created a site to answer all of your
questions
from sports to food service health and
safety technology
it is all there so we decided to dive in
on how exactly it's working taking a
look at transportation